big thanks to kippo for sponsoring this
video what's kippo you ask well it's a
dating app
for gamers ages 18 and up according to
digital trends it was the number one
dating app of the year 2020.
it's super easy to set up and offers
some fun quirky ways to match up with
others by letting you do things like
list your favorite games or make use of
cards which could be anything from
talking about your favorite anime to
your cute little pets
now i'm lucky enough to already be in a
relationship with the most beautiful
girl in the world so for people like me
kippo has the option called friends only
if you want to look for you know friends
but who cares about friends am i right
let's ask someone who's actually using
it for dating about the app
so am i correct in assuming you actually
met zelda in this app
that's amazing could we take a peek at
your profile wow
great stuff man you should be proud so
whether you're like me and you just want
to find some friends to play some games
with or you like link here and you want
to find people to play around with and
click the link in the description below
to get kippo today and now on to the
video
samus iran has a very particular way of
dealing with her problems
you see if a problem appears before our
beloved bounty hunter
normally the response is to shoot it
until it is no longer a problem
it's a very simple but effective method
so effective in fact that most of her
enemies have pretty much been wiped out
of existence by this point
this is why metroid dread the first 2d
metroid game in 19 years to canonically
continue
samus's legacy of intergalactic
domination is such a big deal
and why i've come up with a theory as to
who or what
might be the bounty hunter's next and
potentially final
enemy on that note though let's get a
couple disclaimers out of the way before
entering the theory realm
this video is going to have some pretty
major spoilers in it for all of the
other 2d metroid games so consider
yourself warned if you haven't played or
read the story so far
and real quick for those of you that are
either completely new to the franchise
or are still scratching your head
wondering what the difference is between
metroid 4 and metroid prime 4 allow me
to explain the metroid franchise is
split into two main story lines that
have the same origin and exist
on the same timeline you have the
original metroid storyline which
consists of the 2d or
side scroller games which each have a
unique game title as well as
chronological number assigned to them
such as metroid 3 being also known as
super metroid or metroid 5 being known
as
metroid red on the other hand you have
the metroid prime games which take
place in their entirety between the 2d
games metroid 1
aka 0 mission and metroid 2 aka the
return of samus
now with the groundwork laid for the
content in this video the last thing i'd
like to say is if you enjoyed this video
please consider leaving a like below to
get this video spread around on youtube
and
let me know if you'd like to see more
metroid content since this is actually
the first time i'm experimenting with
the franchise and i'd love to do more
and be sure to subscribe if you haven't
already to stick around for much more
nintendo content to come
there's a lot of backstory to cover in
this video so for your convenience if
you'd like to skip sections or return to
sections
i'll have the video separated into
chapters with time stamps on the
timeline for easy access
let's begin by recapping the ending of
metroid fusion and therefore samus's
last known status
following the events of super metroid
samus had finally fulfilled her duty to
the galactic federation and eliminated
the last metroid in existence
or so she thought see she had a bunch of
baby metroid particles rained down on
her from said last metroid in the final
battle
which is an ending to a whole other
dramatic storyline that i won't get into
at this time
the particles of this baby metroid that
was killed in the climactic battle were
taken off of
samus's power suit and ironically used
illegally by some secret galactic
federation scientists in order to create
you guessed it more metroids including a
queen metroid in fact which spawned the
events of the game metroid other
m which i guess you could call metroid
3.5 samus once again kills this new
metroid and thus halts production of new
metroids and once again the universe is
free of their presence entirely
but then the federation realized that
they kind of messed up when they ordered
samus to kill all the metroids see
they deemed the metroid species too
dangerous to exist
due to several reasons mainly their
parasitic nature and the fact that evil
forces such as the space pirates could
easily multiply the metroid's numbers
and use metroids for galactic conquest
what the federation didn't know though
was that the metroids were actually
created by the ancient
but extinct civilization of highly
advanced
bird people known as the chozo the chozo
who were also the people who created
samus's power armor and were responsible
for raising samus
created the metroids for the sole
purpose of preying on the real biggest
threat to the cosmos
known as the x parasite an all-consuming
and
all-assimilating parasite that feasts on
and then controls living organisms after
consuming those organisms
memories and skills with no limit to the
amount of organisms it can control
no limit to the amount of times it can
reproduce asexually
and no natural predators the literal
universe ending threat potential in the
x parasite is precisely why the chozo
created the metroids which became the
predators of the x and had nearly wiped
them out of existence on their home
planet known as
sr-388 until a certain bounty hunter
under order of the galactic federation
came in and killed all the metroids
cue the events of metroid fusion which
is a metroid game that ironically has
very little to do with actual metroids
two very big things happen to samus
biologically in this game that i want to
make sure everyone knows before going
forward
the first is that she actually gets
infected with the dreaded
x parasite when she was on planet sr 388
assisting a research team from the
biologic space laboratories which is a
research extension of the galactic
federation
they were researching life forms on the
planet when an ex-possessed hornode
attacked them
samus was able to kill it easily of
course but doing so
released the x which then entered
samus's power suit
long story short it infected her suit
and subsequently samus herself
after which she was rushed to doctors
aboard the biologic space laboratory
station who had no clue how to help and
was given a one percent chance of
survival as the parasite
ate her molecules however some
scientists got the idea to formulate a
vaccine
using a cell culture that they kept from
the last metroid this vaccine cured
samus immediately and turned samus's dna
partially into metroid dna making her
share the metroid characteristics of
being able to consume the x parasite but
also making her vulnerable to cold
temperatures so now
samus is part metroid in all seems well
but while she was busy getting healed
the ex that remained in her power suit
decided it would become a corrupted
x version of samus since that's kind of
what the x parasite does
and thus the first of the dreaded sax
parasites was formed which are all evil
copies of samus at her full power
fast forward to the end of the game when
samus finally meets and defeats one of
these
ex-doppelgangers upon its defeat it
released its nucleus or rather its core
x and was then fully absorbed by samus
who at this point was said to be
restored to her pre-vaccine state and no
longer possessed a vulnerability to cold
after this
samus is once again able to use her ice
beam and defeats a metroid in its omega
stage of development
because the galactic federation had been
breeding them in a restricted lab aboard
the space station
and after defeating this omega metroid
samus realizes the axe has been breeding
all throughout the biologic space
laboratory station
and decides that the only way to save
the world is to crash the entire station
into the planet sr-388 and
blows it and the entire planet and
everything on it
to smithereens once again using her
highly effective strategy
she has not only rid the world of all
remaining metroids and metroid cell
cultures but also
the dreaded x parasite well all except
for one
samus iran was afflicted fatally by the
x parasite which began altering her on a
molecular level
this was only resolved when she became
partially metroid and therefore equipped
the fusion suit
and thus gained an immunity to the x so
metroid dna samus ran around as
partially metroid until the very end of
metroid fusion
when she ate a core x and became omega
suit samus
which was the last version of samus we
saw before metroid dreads reveal
this is crucial information because it
implies that samus is essentially
both metroid and x parasite in the same
individual
the fact that she isn't dead after
absorbing the core x is proof enough
that she still has metroid dna in her
as well as the fact that she directly
states in her personal log in metroid
dread that she is still immune to the x
parasite
and the fact that she gained lost
abilities and a new suit by
adding the x parasite to her dna at the
end of the game
implies that there must be a perfect
balance of metroid
and x that exists within her otherwise
she would either be dead from a lack of
metroid dna or she would not have the
omega suit from a lack of ex-parasite
both have to be present for samus to
exist as she did when she flew away at
the end of metroid fusion
and this is heavily implied to still be
the case to some degree since her suit
in metroid dread
we'll call it the dread suit bears some
striking similarities to the fusion suit
in both its slimmer fit and blue
organic material present all over what
this means is that the universe is not
yet completely rid of metroid's or the
axe parasite
samus iran is the last of either of
these species
whether we're talking about samus the
space pirates the metroids or the
ex-parasite the common denominator that
links samus's destiny with those parties
is the galactic federation the
federation has generally been considered
the force of good in the games which is
why samus didn't really mind doing jobs
for them you know like the genocide of
an entire species a couple times there
however after you peel back the surface
of lore in the franchise
you'll find many reasons to question the
federation's moral standings
such as they have space pirate spies
among their ranks
or the many different attempts they've
made to secretly and sometimes straight
up illegally create weapons of mass
destruction like when they repeatedly
tried to breed metroids to use as
bioweapons or when they created clones
of mother brain and ridley or
even when they tried to replicate
samus's power suit and morphball
clearly the federation has been shown to
take on a much darker and
even sometimes villainous role
especially since the events of metroid
fusion
you see earlier when i was recapping
samus status after fusion
i skipped over the parts where she
directly rebelled against the federation
twice actually once was after she
discovered the restricted lab aboard the
biologic space laboratory that was
breeding metroids
upon her discovery she had inadvertently
also led the sax into the lab
upon which the lab went into emergency
mode launched itself into space
and blew itself up her galactic
federation computer named
atom which is the same computer that
she's shown talking to in dread
was obviously very upset at this and
scolded her for causing the restricted
lab's destruction and then
instructed her to basically stand down
and wait for the federation to
investigate the x further because
get this the federation saw potential in
the x parasite for weapons
are you starting to see a pattern here
anyway of course samus who knows how
dangerous the x is first hand is
unwilling to give it a chance at
galactic domination she disagrees and
disobeys adam's orders
of standing down after apparently
convincing adam to see things her way
she then rebels against the federation
once again by destroying their biologic
space lab as well as the entire planet
of
sr-388 which they were trying to study
as semes flies off into the distance at
the end of the game
she says to her computer friend adam
that she doubts anyone
meaning the federation will ever
understand why she destroyed the x and
even directly states that the federation
will most likely hold her responsible
for this rebellion so as of the events
leading up to metroid dredd
samus has become part metroid part x
parasite defied the federation on
several accounts
and destroyed two entire planets as well
as the biologic space
lab and everyone on it now let's talk
about metroid dread
one of the only things we're able to
know about samus's new adventure
in metroid dread is that she's being
hunted by these strange
seemingly indestructible robots known as
extraplanetary multi-form mobile
identifiers
or e-m-m-i for short according to the
official game's website
the emmy were created and dispatched to
the unknown distant planet known as
zdr by none other than the galactic
federation
the purpose of these robots is
apparently to capture and extract dna
from unknown creatures
according to samus's own log the
federation received some sort of cryptic
video that apparently held evidence of
the x parasites still living somewhere
they were apparently able to trace the
signal's origin to the distant planet
zdr and then launched a research unit
along with
seven emmy robots to apparently find and
extract the axe parasite
the research unit allegedly disappeared
once they arrived on the planet when
samus learned of all this
she said does the x truly still exist
and just what is happening on zdr
it's up to me the only one immune to the
x parasite
to go find out and then decided to fly
off to planet zdr and get involved with
all of this
of her own volition now it's possible
that the metroid devs are legitimately
just
adding in more x parasite on a new
unknown planet
kind of randomly but let's assume for
the time being that the chozo were
correct
when they researched and found that the
x parasite is only present on the planet
sr-388 and had not yet begun to
repopulate on other planets
after all that is the entire reasoning
behind their decision to contain the x
parasite to
its native planet and why they created
the metroids in the first place and
released them on said planet
if this is true then samus really did
rid the world of the x when she
destroyed the planet including everyone
and everything
on it and the biologic space station
which were the only two places in
existence that the x was present in
given that samus herself stated that the
federation would hold her accountable
for these actions and would not
understand her reasoning for destroying
the x and the federation's proven
history of secretive and even illegal
weapons projects
here's the big question that potentially
all of the events of metro dread are
centered around
what if the federation has lured samus
to this random remote planet of zdr
because she has the last remaining x
parasite within her own
dna and the emmy robots are supposed to
hunt
her what if metroid red is a trap for
the bounty hunter
think about it there are no living
galactic federation researchers or
scientists on the planet i'd imagine
just in case
samus blows it up again the emmy robots
are also suspiciously
far more powerful than is necessary for
their purposes as
research robots and when they kill samus
they send some sort of probe into her
body which could very possibly be
extracting her dna
which would line up perfectly with their
stated purpose we know for a fact that
the federation is obsessed with
developing
massively powerful weapons from
biological sources and they haven't ever
been able to truly give
up trying with metroid and x parasites
so extracting both metroid and x dna or
some sort of
indestructible perfect balance of the
two while ridding themselves of the only
one that could possibly stand in their
way
samus iran is the perfect two birds with
one stone scenario that is exactly the
kind of thing the federation would try
to pull off and since the dev team
directly stated on the game's website
that this game will
end samus's connection to the metroids
once and for all
logically the only way to truly do so
would be to end her connection with the
ones who
just can't let it all go the common
denominator
the galactic federation themselves and
because this will
end the metroid species legacy i think
it's entirely possible that either the
federation
samus herself or both will no longer
exist by the end of the game
metroid dredd may be samus iran's
final battle but that's all just my
theory what do you guys think did samus
make an enemy of the galactic federation
due to her rebellion in metroid fusion
or is everything forgiven and this is
all just an innocent play at obtaining
more x parasite
with killer robots that are trying to
kill samus let me know in the comments
below
also thank you so very much for watching
i've wanted to cover metroid for a while
now
and i even announced back in february
that i was going to
it took me a few months but here we are
if you enjoyed this video please
consider dropping a like below to get it
spread to other metroid fans out there
and make sure you're subscribed if you
haven't already because at this point
who knows what i may cover next
huge thanks as always to my amazing
bandit crew of which i have lots of new
names to announce
say hello to tiny elf melissa oh jared b
oogabooga playmaker duel lynx lid 8bit
and adam s who have all recently joined
the ranks of my elite
seriously you guys are the best of the
best and if you watching are interested
in helping these videos get made
please check out that join button below
or follow the links in my description
for my patreon and merge pages
also down there are the links to my
other social media pages so come on over
and follow me on twitter for more
thoughts and comments from yours truly
that's all i've got for this one so as
always i hope you have a wonderful rest
of your day
this is maskingtonabandit signing out
and looking forward to seeing you in the
next one
[Music]
you